[Music]
hello I'm David is my wife Emily we live
in San Antonio Texas I'm a high school
teacher and coach I'm a physical
therapist I can remember being in my
third year of college blind didn't
living on student loans and I met Emily
and she was on her own deal and doing
her thing yeah
single mom with two kids paying the
mortgage car payments with student loans
just about to graduate to you when I met
you you just about to finish college so
I can remember going into the financial
aid office and the way it works is they
offer you all of these amounts of money
and you just checkmark which ones you
want your tuition is deducted and you
get a check for the leftover amount I'm
growing up you know at that time the MTV
the English bulldog shows were around so
I took the money and I went to petland I
went to the store and just went and
bought a $2,000 English Bulldog one
hundred percent on borrowed money that I
didn't realize I was borrowing
and yeah it's a fun time we grew up
thinking a student loans are normal
everybody has credit cards they're for
emergencies and that's a land so I mean
we had all that and to hear and to
realize that what we were doing was just
pretty much ruining our future like I
didn't even save college for my sons I
had none to that done didn't even
realize that how important that was and
so we're paying for all those mistakes
that were kind of engraved in our head
and I was just so sick of it I just
wanted that ability to enjoy my money I
can remember distinctly when we're about
to get married I went to get a ring and
I got denied the loan amount or the
credit card to buy the ring and that was
a pretty pretty sad moment for me yeah
as a woman you worry more about
financial stability with your with your
home it was very scary I had a lot of
anxiety in the beginning a lot of
anxiety I mean it's it's overwhelming
unbelievably overwhelming so I started
listening to Dave Ramsey on the radio a
lot it got pretty into it and tried to
get him to start listening to it I found
out they were coming to sign trying to
an actually a friend of mine and her
husband out went to the one I think is a
year before and I was like let's go
let's try it out just just listen to
what he has to say
until we went to that event that kind of
got me on board yeah that was a turning
point for us
I go back to putting it all on her
encouraging me so when she took him to
the event I sat there and actually
getting into it I was taking notes and
so I can remember it I think it was the
following weekend she's like our let's
do this like we got on the phone and you
know how long it takes to get people on
the phone and when you look up loan one
loan two loan three loan for dog you
start adding all that up and it's just
incredible that moment though when we
finally got our whiteboard and we laid
everything out was extremely eye open
depressing it was do yeah very
depressing it was I went from feeling
like I was you know making all this
money to I was dirt poor and I was like
I just finished I'm not supposed to be
poor anymore I think the white board the
white board did it seen it every day
multiple times as you walked by it right
in the dining room or anybody anybody
that came over our house would see it
because we were looking at it we were
like all right we're two years into this
like this thing needs to be done already
[Music]
right after we started doing getting on
budget starting to do the Dave Ramsey
plan I was about two three months
pregnant with our first daughter and New
Year's Eve we get a phone call that our
house was on fire
so right when we decided to start
getting on track we lost everything the
house was a total loss and there's no
feeling like you're you just had a
realization of how much debt you have
and what situation you're actually in
and all of a sudden they get a phone
call that your house is on fire you pull
up to that scene and it is literally
burning and that is a mouth drum that is
one of those points where you're like oh
my goodness so everything goes on top
later on as we got going it grew inside
me the sickness of what it is I had to
do at that time my daughter was one and
I had nothing save for her for college
and it terrified me
[Music]
that's when we started really taking off
really at that point I mean it we
probably paid off more in that 12-month
period than we did in the entire four
years that we went through this journey
it's crazy it's just amazing how much
money you have when you have no bills
when you change your mentality so you
know you ended up spending money better
you make better choices you take your
time buying things because that's your
cash there's not it's not gonna be a
payment that someone else's financing so
I mean just like when we we want it
solar panels because it's so funny now
we want to cut everything out of our
lives like okay how can we cut our
electricity bill so let's get solar
panels we saved up cash and we paid for
solar panels so our house is running
almost with no electricity yeah and that
guy was like so how much how long doing
a finance these four you know we have a
great financing we're like no no tell me
how much it's gonna cost and I'll get
back to you when I can pay for it and
that's basically the way it works now
and for us it's just changing our whole
way of living
it literally warps your mind like it's
it's it's almost like it goes in and it
rewires you
I think it's life-changing it literally
can save marriages and I think it might
have for us I mean it and so at this
point I I mean I just try to spread the
word to anyone that's willing to listen
[Music]
at the other day when this was all said
and done it took us roughly four years
we had all of our student loan debt and
my credit debt and her credit did the
house fire that added some of that
I think it added up to about two hundred
and thirty thousand dollars give or take
all of the adversity that we hid and all
of the things that we went through it
changed my life it changed our lives it
changed the family it changed it was it
can be done it's possible I'll tell you
that much a million times
III need FPU just to try to spread the
word like literally just to help someone
I mean I let it in my living room I
didn't realize what I was doing while I
was in college I didn't know this going
in to the real world it's possible if
you just give it a shot if you just jump
in and you know there's gonna be a lot
of craziness along the way because life
happens right I mean it life is gonna
happen it's gonna happen to everyone I
promise you I tell my students that all
the time
life is gonna happen alright David and
Emily Omar Sadie and Aubrey count it
down let's hear a debt free scream three
two one
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]